you said that as a kid you actually
thought about birds a lot you wanted to
be a crow yeah that was my I still
that's my number one I know now it's not
gonna happen
you know it's not gonna happen pretty
sure but you don't know anything can
happen you could be tomorrow in the next
here's the thing I what is it that you
like about crows I like that they're
very independent that you see them
everywhere in the world I mean they're
basically like cockroaches or coyotes or
sharks right very common yeah they're
common they're they're self-sufficient
they're very independent they are
they're kind of treacherous they'll
steal from you though they'll do
whatever they're opportunists yeah
they're they can handle anything seems
like they're invincible I do
and a beautiful there I have to say that
there whenever there's a crow around and
it makes the sound that you just made
huh ah I feel like it is I feel like
it's mocking me and then probably that's
my personality but so I was like you
know and I become enraged that's more
like a raven that was you that was a
raven yeah so your
and sometimes just a break what's that I
don't know what that is okay
that's me after a lot I've had a couple
of them I've rescued some in front of my
house when I used to live in Los Angeles
kids unfortunately tend to shoot at him
with BB guns when we're sitting on the
phone lines and then they break their
wings and they and twice I found you
know with one wing hanging and I've
caught him put him in a box and taking
them to vet and once they fixed up the
crow another time they couldn't write
that's really nice of you that I mean
you have a lot of something give a lot
of empathy yeah Wow
crows in particular I like all animals I
like how I give you a real out I'd am
ready I'd let it die your real [ __ ]
other animals get out of here dog oh
whoa how are you
you